Good morning John, and sorry for this unscheduled video,
But as you know, Neil Armstrong has died, and it's super sad.
And I wax poetic all over the place in my video on SciShow,
so if you wanna see that, you can go see that.
But now, instead of talking about the symbolic nature of this great,
I just wanna talk about how Neil Armstrong was pretty freakin' badass.
He did many amazing things, of course,
but today we're gonna talk about the 6 MOST amazing things that Neil Armstrong ever did.
#1: The first amazing cool thing that Neil Armstrong ever did
is that he got his pilot's license before he was legally allowed to get hid driver's license.
Which is pretty amazing.
And a great way to get a leg up on the competition
if you wanted to become the first man on the moon,
which I'm sure was not his goal when he was 16 years old, but still!
But in addition to helping him out in getting to the moon,
it also ensured he would be the youngest person in his squadron in the Korean War,
where he flew 78 missions, one of which ended when he got hit by artillery fire
and had to fly all the way back to base and then eject because
there was no way for him to land the plane.
#2: While working as a test pilot for aircraft
Neil Armstrong flew over 200 different types of planes!
And during that particular career, he almost died around 3 times.
Once when he and Chuck Yeager were doing a touch-and-go landing on a salt flat that was muddy.
Once when his X-15 bounced off the atmosphere, sending him 40 miles off course
with limited fuel reserves.
And once when he was landing his plane and his landing gear collapsed underneath him
and he had to power out of the landing, smashing the tail of his plane on the runway.
It destroyed the radio and released the hydraulic fluid.
*sarcastic* Yeah!
#3: And another time Neil Armstrong almost died!
Gemini 8, of which Neil Armstrong was
the command pilot
was the first mission to ever dock 2 vehicles
together in outer space.
And as soon as it happened,
they started spinning uncontrollably.
While spinning at 1 revolution a second,
(That's pretty sickeningly fast)
Armstrong aborted the mission, separated the craft, corrected the roll,
saving his and his pilot's life.
#4: Now, when they were planning on how
to build the lunar lander,
they had this test thing called the LLRV.
And it was basically just a chair strapped to a jet engine.
While test driving that thing, one of the little jets
on the side failed,
Armstrong had to try and get the thing right side up
for a moment, so he could eject, and this happened like 30 feet above the ground!
Before the thing hit the ground and exploded
into a giant ball of fire!
Later analysis showed that if he had ejected
0.5 seconds later, he would have died.
And that's not even the amazing part!
Neil Armstrong, after that, did a little press conference with some reporters,
and then went back to work.
People came by and were like "Dude, I heard that you almost just died! What are you doing here?"
And Neil was like "I had some paperwork to do."
#5: Neil Armstrong threatened to sue his barber.
Now this seems like kind of a jerk move.
Dude's been cuttin' you hair for 20 years and he gives you 1 bad haircut you threaten to sue him?!
But no! He threatened to sue him because the guy took some of Neil Armstrong's hair
and sold it to a celebrity hair collector.
Neil found out about it and was like "You get me my hair back or you donate that money to charity
or I will sue your barbershop right out from under you!"
And unable to retrieve the hair, the guy donated the $3000 to charity.
Good on you, Neil!
Good on you.
And finally, #6: Neil Armstrong walked on the freaking moon.
But before that, he landed the LEM (Lunar Excursion Module) on the moon.
In order to do that, he had to override the computer,
just like Luke Skywalker "I'm gonna use the force!"
So the computer was taking them down into a crater with big, like car-sized
Rocks in it and he diverted.
Everybody's freaking out, like "What's Neil doing!"
He gets there, lands the LEM: 30 seconds of fuel left.
30 seconds away
from our first foray into another world ending in tragedy!
In having 2 men, still, dead on the moon, their bodies still there.
Imagine the impact that would've had on our national psyche!
But that's not what happened.
Because Neil Armstrong was a freakin' badass.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.